If you want to hear about how every story
from the original trilogy of Scary Stories
books was used in the movie, then stick around
to the end of this video.
It is the Fall of 1968 in a small town called
Mill Valley, Pennsylvania and Halloween is
being celebrated in full force.
One thing I noticed was a poster for The Halloween
Horror Double Bill, which presumably was a
reference to the double feature taking place
at the drive in, where we would later see
the characters watch Night of the Living Dead.
But the double bill might also be self-referential,
because at the end of the movie we learn that
the ending is left open for a possible sequel.
That’s not the only bit of foreshadowing
early on.
One of the main characters, Chuck, wants to
be Spiderman for Halloween, but his mom ends
up making him a literal spider costume.
His sister, Ruth, bickers with him because
she sees him as a pest, pun intended -- the
first example of her distaste for arachnids.
Shortly after, when they go to check out the
haunted house, we see that the place is crawling
with spiders -- and at the end of that sequence,
Tommy pushes Ruth into the locked room, where
she gets spider webs caught in her hair, which
is likely where she first receives the bite
that becomes infected with spider eggs, known
as The Red Spot.
But I’ll discuss that further when we get
to it.
First, let’s talk about the first supernatural
sight, the old lady with the black doberman
seen by Chuck in the haunted house.
This is likely part of the corrupt Bellows
family that we learn more about throughout
the movie, but the imagery of a black dog
is one that comes up a couple times in Alvin
Schwartz’s trilogy of books, most notably
the appropriately titled story: The Black
Dog, from the third book.
In that story, a man named Peter Rothberg
lives alone in an old house.
Every night at 11PM, a mysterious black dog
appears and runs down his stairs.
He tries night after night to catch it, but
it's unsuccessful, until one day his neighbor
sets up downstairs with a pistol.
The dog disappears, never to be seen again,
but he can still hear the dog running on most
nights.
Like the dog in the story, this is the only
time Chuck gets a look at the dog, and naturally,
his friends don’t believe him at first.
Stella and Ramón happen across the room that
Sarah Bellows was locked away in, and it is
there that they discover two items, the music
box and Sarah’s book of scary stories.
When they find the book, there are a number
of stories already written inside, and they
correspond to actual stories in from the books
that the movie is sourced from.
The ones I noticed included: May I Carry Your
Basket, a story about a man who offers to
help an old woman out in the cold one night
with her basket, only to discover that the
basket contains her head, which attacks him;
Somebody Fell From Aloft, the story of a mysterious
corpse that falls onto a ship at sea; The
Ghost With The Bloody Fingers, the story of
a bloody hand that haunts hotel guests; The
Hook, the story of an escaped convict with
a hook for a hand, Strangers, a story about
a man who meets a woman reading ghost stories
on the train who proclaims he doesn’t believe
in ghosts only to see the woman vanish before
him; The Attic, about a guy who steps on a
nail in the attic; Cat’s Paw, about a man
who shoots the cat who is continually shooting
meat from his smokehouse, only to discover
that it was actually a shapeshifting witch
who was also (plot twist) his neighbor’s
wife; and Wendigo, the story of a hunter who
goes out on a trip with a Native American
guide named DeFago, a name I’m sure never
got him made fun of at all during middle school,
who essentially gets dragged away by this
Algonquian mythological creature known as
the Wendigo.
Then there’s a blank page, and on the page
after that Stella sees the beginnings of another
story, Harold.
She smears the red ink with her finger, as
if to suggest that the words had just been
written and the ink, or as we later find blood,
was freshly.
In the movie, the jock character Tommy lives
on a farm with his mother, and he and his
friends continually abuse this scarecrow,
Harold, by throwing bottles and hitting it
with a bat, until one night Harold comes to
life and stabs Tommy with a pitchfork, causing
him to turn into an ugly scarecrow.
The involvement of the character Tommy is
kind of hidden in plain sight in the movie,
because the story in the book centers around
two farmers, one of which is named Thomas.
In the book, they create Harold resemble a
farmer they don’t like and similarly abuse
the scarecrow, but instead of turning Thomas
into a scarecrow, Harold skins him and sets
the skin out to dry in the sun.
The next story to play out in the movie is
the Big Toe.
Unlike Harold, the name of the character in
the Big Toe is never stated, but in the movie,
the name August corresponds with one of Stella’s
two best friends, Augie.
In the book, the boy friends the toe out in
the garden, and so his mom puts it into her
soup, which is ridiculous, so in the movie,
he just finds the stew which appears in the
fridge and contains the toe and various other
body parts.
The next story is The Red Spot, which is another
one where the name of the character, Ruth,
nicely corresponds with the name of the character
from the original story.
In the book, Ruth’s boil bursts to release
the spiders who had nested in her face while
she’s in the bath, but in the movie, she
rushes into the school bathroom before her
production of Bye Bye Birdie -- which was
likely chosen because it’s about a rockstar
named Conrad Birdie who is to perform one
last hit before being drafted into the army,
much like how the character Ramón’s final
act is helping rescue Stella before he is
taken overseas by the draft.
The kids try rush to save Ruth from popping
open the red spot, but accidentally run into
the wrong bathroom, where there are these
four girls are just standing in the dark…
wait, what was going on in that first bathroom?
But anyway, after that, they go to visit Lou
Lou Baptiste, who has a matching music box
to the one we previously saw in Sarah Bellows’s
room, but this time we get to hear it play,
and the tune is a song known as “The Hearse
Song.”
You see, the Scary Stories books are not only
filled with Scary Stories, but also games
/ pranks to play at Halloween parties or songs
complete with lyrics and sheet music.
I’m not a musician but I was able to recognize
the melody from the only lyrics that Lou Lou
mentions about the worms crawling and the
fact that there’s an audiobook version,
where some old guy sings the song.
Roll it.
“Don’t you ever laugh, as the hearse goes
by.
For you may be the next to die.
They wrap you up in a big white sheet.
From your head down to your feet.”
Oh no… this song is so scary…
But it’s around this time that Chuck starts
to mention that he’s been having this recurring
dream, which eventually leads to his own scary
story encounter, where this creature known
as The Pale Lady corners him from every direction,
and eventually catches him and absorbs him.
The book version is similar but with different
circumstances.
An artist named Lucy Morgan decides to go
out of town to do some painting, but her destination
changes after a pale lady in a dream tells
her that this is an evil place.
She ends up going to a town called Dorset,
and when she goes to look at her room, it
is the same as the location from her dream,
just like how Chuck’s dream had described
the Red Room, which is the room in the hospital
that the kids are looking for.
Lucy ends up fleeing the town after seeing
The Pale Lady from her dream, but Chuck isn’t
so lucky.
The next one is one that I really did not
expect to see in the movie adaptation, Me
Tie Doughty Walker -- a story from the original
Scary Stories To Tell In The Dark Book.
The film version has our characters locked
in a jail cell where this creature called
The Gangly Man assembles itself after the
dog at the police station watches its body
parts fall down the chimney, and it goes after
Ramón.
The book kind of establishes the legend that
Ramón and Stella encounter.
It tells of a man who offers $200 to anyone
who stays in this haunted house overnight.
A boy decides to try it and goes there with
his dog.
He goes there and hears someone in the distance
singing the lyrics: “Me tie doughty walker.”
And then his dog responds by signing “Lynchee
kinchy colly molly dingo dingo.”
If you listen to the dog’s grunting in the
film, it actually sounds like he is grunting
these lyrics.
The singing gets closer until the head falls
down the chimney, and in the book, that’s
where it ends, but the movie really takes
it a step further by having it be the head
of a creature that continues to come after
Ramón.
That would seemingly be the last one, but
we eventually come to find out that this entire
thing was part of one big scary story, and
that is The Haunted House.
Here’s the low-down on The Haunted House.
It’s the 10th story in book number one,
and it follows a preacher who goes to investigate
a house said to have been haunted for the
last 10 years.
The ghost of a woman appears and tells the
preacher the story of how her husband killed
her for her money and buried her in the cellar.
She instructs the man to give her a proper
burial, and put her finger in the collection
plate at church, where it will stick to the
man who is guilty.
After he’s done this, she’ll tell him
where the money is hidden, and it’s his
to keep.
This may not sound like anything from the
movie, until you consider the fact that this
is essentially the WHOLE movie.
These kids wander into a haunted house and
come across the book from Sarah Bellows.
Little by little, they learn more and more
about her family abused her and killed her
for trying to expose the truth, about how
her family’s paper mill poisoned the water
supply and got some kids killed.
She’s bringing her killers to justice just
as the woman’s ghost in the haunted house
story did, and instead of publicly exposing
the killer as seen in the book, she gets Stella,
the girl who a few short days ago was too
afraid to write for her school newspaper,
to write in the book and bring the truth out
about Sarah’s death…
Even though I’m pretty sure it’s been
70 years and nobody cares anymore.
But still, this one small action somehow fixes
everything.
It’s just like it was told in the beginning
of the movie: stories hurt and stories heal.
And we roll the credits, which are played
over graphics done in the same style as the
original artwork from the book trilogy.
So that’s it.
Scary Stories To Tell In The Dark Number 1.
I recently also did a video on the Top 5 Things
You Missed from It number one.
So click the video on the left to see that,
and if you like horror you’re definitely
going to want to subscribe to CZsWorld because
I upload new horrors every week, RING that
deathbell for notifications and I’ll see
you in the next video.
Assuming we both survive.